he's waiting for you in the dark he sits
cross-legged still as a placid lake and
patient as a praying monk six feet deep
in meditation he's been like this for so
long his body oil slicked with deadly
black grease skin ancient and haggard
eyes black and flat with the kind of
calm you'd only find in crawling insects
and great white sharks his lipless mouth
is stretched across his jawbone in an
ugly black rictus he may be an old man
but trust us he's got plenty of new
tricks he'd love to show you he sat in
the loneliest place in the world the
deep dark bowels of an scp foundation
containment site surrounded by a complex
confluence of containment measures
different shapes running liquids bright
lights the kind of steel so thick a
nuclear weapon would only leave it
scuffed all the things that had a
tendency to
confuse him because that's all they ever
did the old man laughed to himself very
quietly all the people out there are so
scared of him because of one immutable
fact he isn't trapped here he's just
resting by virtue of his unique
anomalous abilities to pass through
solids at will and resist any form of
physical damage they can dull out there
is no way to really contain him like all
the others all the scp foundation could
hope to do was make leaving inconvenient
enough for him to make his little
adventures on the outside less appealing
than just sitting around doing nothing
after all he had all the time in the
world when you always have a leader
there's a lot less pressure to do
anything now
like all thinking creatures and please
be aware that scp-106
the wretched terrifying old man is very
much a thinking creature he was subject
to occasional boredom and when most
people are bored they might play a video
game watch a few youtube videos or
re-watch it's always sunny in
philadelphia for the fifth time but for
the old man killing boredom involved
well killing people but not just killing
people of course truth be told for him
killing was really the least
entertaining part of the whole affair
the screams the begging the desperate
pleas
warm tears on shaking cheeks convulsions
of pain cold sweats
fear so intense it gives way to
gibbering madness the dull sheen of dead
hope in their eyes when they realize
that their doom is inevitable and that
he their captor their torturer would
decide the exact moment they slipped
into the void of that that was what he
lived for if you could call what the old
man did living he cracked his neck and
licked his teeth was he salivating all
those thoughts about pain seemed to have
got him worked up he could feel the
distant thumping of his heart old black
blood pumping through the dusty
corridors of his vascular system
synapses booming and sparking with
excitement at the thought of plumbing
new depths of human misery like a
scholar of suffering a pioneer of pain
all those silly foundation drones with
the audacity to think they're in control
he'd teach them to scream again
meanwhile in the room for the old man's
containment chamber all hell was
breaking loose monitors on the monster's
vitals were all spiking heart and brain
activity peaked just as they always did
before the old man decided to get active
cameras in his containment chamber
showed him rising steadily to his feet
cracking his joints limbering up his
body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate
pooling around his feet and unleashing
squalls of noxious fumes as it melted
into the floor
years of foundation testing and they
still couldn't find any material that
could withstand that vile black slob as
the old man began strolling towards the
wall a containment specialist in the
control room grabbed a nearby phone and
sounded the alarm for the containment
breach they needed a mobile task force
and every guard on site mobilized to
tackle 106 before he got into the
facility proper and started causing
havoc they couldn't risk it escaping
either the infamous incident when the
old man escaped for a halloween massacre
still haunted the nightmares of many a
staff member he had to be stopped now
a small fighting force was quickly armed
and assembled along with armor and
several high-intensity portable lights
to hopefully slow the monster down in
time for them to grab a d-class and set
up the femur breaker by the time they
all reach the hallway they intended to
use as a choke point for the escape the
old man was already halfway through the
outer layer of defense phasing through
the wall with that same terrible manic
grin he always had when he was about to
inflict terrible violence for the sheer
fun of it the guards and task force
members trained their lights and weapons
on him all of them had seen terrible
things on the job the kind of things
that would saddle almost anyone with a
lifetime of trauma but almost nothing
compared to the horror of direct
engagement during a 106 containment
breach that terrible old coffin dodger
was hell on two legs when they
discovered to their horror that the
lights didn't seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated they fell
back on plan b
that bees standing for blast the living
hell out of him with everything they had
the personnel opened fire pumping round
after round into his dark form while
each gave a loud meaty splatter the old
man didn't even flinch when he was close
enough all those months of lethargy gave
way to sudden deadly speed in many ways
the old man was like a crocodile a
fierce and intelligent ambush predator
who conserved his energy wisely he could
seem so deceptively languid that you
could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless but when you got
within arm's reach the sudden quickness
and ferocity would take you off guard
and by then it's already too late
within 30 seconds the old man was the
only thing left alive in that hallway
all the guards and task force operatives
sent to slow him down lay dead dripping
with his black mucus there was silence
save for the quiet fizzing of the mucus
eating into their clothes and skin the
old man sighed how boring he'd killed so
many people now it all started to seem a
little
samey how many screams could you hear
before they all just blended into a
single shrill wine you can get sick of
even your favorite meal if you eat it
too often but that didn't matter the old
man had a different order of business
today he happened to be inside an scp
foundation containment facility filled
with so many fascinating specimens of
non-human entities that the one they
called scp-106
simply couldn't wait to torture he'd
only met a small portion of the ones
they had contained here but given what a
fascinating experience his past attack
on his fellow anomalies was he couldn't
wait to meet some more meanwhile the
site's top brass did all they could to
try to mobilize a second response to the
rogue senior citizen from hell currently
strolling through their high security
containment facility could they get in
contact with other mobile task forces
deployed in the area maybe they could
get hammer down or samsara in on this
mess before anything got really out of
hand the old man seemed more intent on
something this time they suspected even
the femur breaker might not work in
luring him back until he claimed
whatever he deemed to be his prize maybe
they should contact the o5 council
security guards were tracking 106's
progress through the facility via their
vast networks of security cameras they
warned any research administration and
janitorial staff to clear out of his
path unless they felt like being
tortured to death he hadn't dragged
anyone into his pocket dimension yet so
whoever that privilege was reserved for
would probably be getting a particular
sticky experience they could only
speculate as to the silent beast's
intentions one guard noticed something
when cross referencing 106's movements
with a map of the facility they were
able to triangulate where he was heading
straight for the containment chamber of
scp-096
the guard's lips curled into a slight
smile thinking if one of you freaks can
actually kill the other maybe something
positive will come out of this disaster
the old man was having a stroll down
memory lane the time prior when he broke
out of his cell and decided to hassle
his fellow inmates was certainly
eventful he wound up in the company of
some cantankerous reptile and a korean
fox woman an unlikely pair if ever there
was one after finding himself in a room
with them he decided they should have a
little more privacy and dragged them
back into his pocket dimension for
further fun
of course with two at once his attention
had been a little split they spent as
much time tussling with each other as
resisting his attempts to torment them
they definitely put him through his
paces that day and he gave far better
than he got after so many hours of
brutal mutilation there was barely any
of the lizard left despite its
frustrating insistence on quickly
healing from so many of its wounds still
it was good exercise even if the results
had been a little less than satisfying
if he could get another anomaly alone
though he'd be able to take his time and
really savor the pain he caused oh that
sounded heavenly
soon he came upon an incredibly strange
containment chamber that quickly caught
his eye it looked like a huge metal cube
with no way in or out not even a seam
whatever was trapped in there the old
man thought it must be something that
even the fools at the scp foundation
really truly wanted nothing to do with
but even more so than the strange sight
it was the sound that drew the old man
in tempting him like a siren song it was
weeping a soft sobbing keen that
betrayed a bottomless well of misery
whatever was making that crying sound
had known true despair or whatever
passes for true despair before you've
had a close encounter with the old man
in his pocket dimension the old man
grinned and thought oh sonny i'll give
you something to really cry about
he stepped forward and phased his way
into the metal cube the creature was in
the corner in contrast to that stupid
lizard this monster was pleasingly
humanoid with presumably all the
familiar pain points
the only real difference was color and
proportion it was far longer and
ganglier than the average human with
grayish skin and no hair anywhere on its
body still it was something the old man
could work with the creature didn't even
seem to register his presence he just
sat crumpled in the corner weeping still
grinning his lunatic grin the old man
approached and rested a moist hand on
the creature's shoulder its pale skin
began to fizzle from the intruder's
corrosive touch a pool of vile sludge
began spreading out beneath his feet
until the creature was encompassed too
little by little they sank into the old
man's favorite place out of the world
the pocket dimension his own personal
eternal infinite dungeon where the only
laws are pain and terror for all but the
old man himself little did he know
this time the scores may be a little
more even on that front they both stood
in that terrifying labyrinth of hallways
and chambers where the old man had made
countless lives infinitely worse than
any terrible afterlife that could follow
them and still this creature didn't seem
to change its reaction he was almost
irritated by it and what's more this
whole time the creature hadn't even
turned to look at him he'd have to fix
that too the old man with his shocking
strength gripped the monster's shoulder
and whipped him around staring into his
face bearing his black eyes and manic
smile but he couldn't help find what
looked back at him
disconcerting its eyes were blank and
white its face stretched and warped into
a permanent grimace like munch's old
painting the scream and the second the
old man laid eyes on it that's exactly
what it did its gaping mouth let out the
most terrible whale the old man had ever
heard in all his years of torturing it
was a scream of unknowable sadness and
fear but somehow the old man sensed that
this creature didn't fear him it feared
itself feared what it was about to do
what the hell had he dragged down here
with him without warning the terrible
whales soon gave way to sudden and
ferocious aggression just like the old
man had dealt out to a group of
foundation guards and mobile task force
agents earlier that same night it was
only out of a mix of pure luck and his
own finely tuned animal instinct that
the old man was able to dodge the first
strike from the creature's long lith
forelimb he couldn't believe it they
were in his special place and this
victim of his had the audacity to fight
back well he'd soon put this monster in
its place as the monster continued
roaring and swiping for him the old man
simply walked backwards into a nearby
wall disappearing into a black stain of
course the monster better known to the
foundation as
scp-096 or the shy guy simply crashed
through the wall to give chase but on
the other side just another wall he
disappeared how typically when something
sees the face of the shy guy he
immediately has a kind of intuitive
connection to them he can sense their
presence it's burned into his mind a
homing beacon an unstoppable imperative
he knows exactly where they are and how
to get them but nothing about this
situation was typical the shy guy felt
all the murderous rage he normally did
but the rest was just static where was
the life he needed to abolish hiding
suddenly the old man emerged behind him
and forced his hand into the shy guy's
back his fist melted straight through
flesh and skin causing the creature to
let out another terrible whale but as
could be expected they didn't leave a
scratch on the shy guy's indestructible
skeleton the shy guy pulled the 180 and
swung for the old man again but he was
already gone here in the pocket
dimension the old man had the ultimate
home turf advantage here space and time
were his playthings in the infinite
twisting labyrinthine walls of the
pocket dimension the old man wasn't just
the devil he was god too but it would
take far more than some cheap tricks and
bodily harm to dissuade the shy guy from
his sole purpose in life he began
running through the old man's personal
maze like a crazed lab rat tearing
through wall after wall forever
searching for the monster that trapped
it here it would see the smiling face of
that rotten old man every so often the
flash of black eyes and dirty teeth and
shadows but every time it tried to
strike the shadows there would be
nothing there and every time he got a
chance the old man would emerge from the
shadows behind the shy guy to strike
back clawing into his flesh and
vanishing again before the trapped beast
could retaliate the nasty old sadist was
now starting to have some fun it was a
reflex test a classic game of
high-stakes whack-a-mole and every time
the creature failed to strike him its
distress only seemed to grow this was
perfectly fine for the old man after all
he enjoyed a little mental torment as
much as he loved physical torture and a
human would have died or given in to
despair long before now this monster's
wonderful mix of resilience and pain
made it a great chew toy the old man
kept up this routine baiting and
striking until something unanticipated
happened he appeared waited for the
swing disappeared as it approached then
reappeared behind the shy guy to deliver
another painful strike this time however
it seemed his victim had anticipated his
pattern before he could hit the creature
the shy guy turned quicker than anything
the old man had ever seen and hit him
with such force he flew through several
walls in his own maze shattering them as
he went he hit the ground stunned by the
fact that the shy guy had actually
landed a hit but he wasn't done the
shrieking monster came bounding after
him before the old man could stand it
struck him again and again and again
pounding his vile body into the ground
which cracked and crumbled the old man
sneered and sank into a puddle of his
mucus on the ground the old man was gone
again
scp-096 screamed in a mix of rage
despair and frustration so consumed with
its hunt that it didn't notice the pool
of corrosive mucus was slowly growing it
began to rise bubbling and hissing at
scp-096's feet getting deeper and deeper
and deeper as the walls rose taller and
taller around it the creature wailed
until a tide of the awful stuff reached
its face and cascaded down its throat
melting all the organs within as the
creature was fully submerged as cp 106
manifested atop the wall and looked down
smiling spitefully he thought oh you may
have had me there boyo but in the end
i always win
nothing
could survive that and yet bubbles still
rose from the slot below the old man
gritted his rotten teeth and balled his
fists in quiet anger moments later back
in our dimension a portal opened in the
ground of
scp-096's containment chamber it vomited
out scp-096's skeleton smothered in
bubbling black goo and scp-106
096 would probably be fully regenerated
within a couple of hours and if 682's
encounter with him was anything to go by
probably extremely unwilling to
interface with the old man and the old
man himself who couldn't help but feel a
little humiliated by the whole
experience was glad the two of them
would probably never meet again
he left the regenerating 096 and
commenced the walk of shame back to his
containment chamber they didn't even
need the femur breaker he just felt like
having a sit down and processing it all
nobody else would ever know what
happened in the pocket dimension that
day and for the old man's pride that was
probably for the best but he'd know he'd
always know by the night's end he was
sitting in his containment chamber again
for lornly wondering god damn old timer
have you lost your age now go check out
scp-096 look at a picture of the shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories and scp-106 the old man origin
theories for more videos on today's
terrifying combatants